عونا لطق تفتيتنا وتقسيمنا على مدى قرون
كل ما نظرتم الى التاريخ
ستجدون الكثير من هذه الامثله همم
ويكفي ان ننظر الى همم كتب التاريخ عن ذلك
همم لقد ااه بعد ذلك قمنا ب همم وضع همم
اعمال همم
من قبل هذه الدول
بتنفيذ ذلك ولكننا نحن كنا دائما
وهو باننا نود ان نكون جزءا من العالم
المعاصر
والحضاري ولكن بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيات التي قمنا همم
تهذيبه بانفسنا كنا من يوم الى يوم مع
الامل بان نكون جزءا من العالم
اا حواري لكن تبين انهم لم يقولوا
بانتظارنا
واقصد هنا
همم
محاولات التي قمنا بها وانا اتخذت هذه
الخطوات ايضا
للاقتراب تقارب المواقف فكان الرد دائما
لا همم بل على العكس كانت همم
خطوات اخرى بما في ذلك دعم ارهابيين في
القوقاز لاضعاف
روسيا
وعدم جعل قيام روسيا جديده ودوله جديده
همم لذلك انتم تعلمون كل ذلك همم
في بدايه التسعينيات حتى بدايه ال في
الثانيه همم
استخدام مثل هذه المجموعات على الاراضي
الروسيه كان مقبولا من قبل بعض الدول وهمم
كانت همم همم فقط
وقاموا بدعمهم ماديا ومعنويا وعسكريا لاهم
ذلك وعسكريا لاضعاف روسيا ولكن بفضل بطوله
قوتنا العسكريه همم قمنا باجتياز هذه
المرحله الصعبه واجتياز هذا الاختبار وهمم
خرجنا منه واقوى وكما يقال القادم اكثر
انه منافسين بداوا يستخدمه كل
شيء ولا اريد ان ازعج احد همم
انهم يستخدمون كل شيء معقول وغير معقول
لتحقيق اهدافهم
ف- اا خاصه اا في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق والان على اوكرانيا
الاتحاد السوفيتي ولكن بعد الانقلاب عام
يبقى المساعدات الماليه والقروض ولكن لم
ينفع شيء من ذلك وبعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وخروج اوكرانيا
وضعت همم
بيانها
لاستقلال
كتبت خلال هذا البيان بان اوكرانيا ستبقى
دوله حياديه كان يمكن ان نفهم ذلك من قبل
القياده في ذلك الحين لان تلك
القياده لم ترى اي اخطار وبالتالي همم كان
هناك همم حضاره مشتركه وتاريخ
انسانيه مشتركه ولكن للاسف
تنجح
لبناء هذه العلاقات التي املنا ووضعنا
اعمال كبيره لبناءها اييي كل هذه
المحاولات لم تكن ناجعه
لتحقيق هذا الهدف واود ان اؤكد هنا بانه
لا يمكن انتقادا ولو من على شيء قمنا بكل
ما في وسعنا تتعلمونا موقفنا كنا دائما
نعتبر الشعب الاوكراني وما الان همم كذلك
همم افكر واؤكد ذلك بان الشعب الاوكراني
هو الشعب شقيق لان لدينا تقاليد مشاركه
وتاريخ مشترك همم
وهذه المشكله
اخرى ثالثا
اه وللاسف لقد نجحوا بتحقيق هدفهم
ووضعونا في مجال المجابهه
وكما قلت بعد
الانقلاب عمل عام 2014
هنا لن اذكر ال ااه الاسباب ولكن كل ما
اقوله انه همم غير مقبول ايه
بعد الانقلاب عام
باربعه عشر ثلاث وزارات خارجيه من بولندا
وفرنسا والمانيا قد وقعوا على مذكره مذكره
التفاهم بين معارضه والرئيس همم
ولكن في اليوم الثالث الجميع ذكر هذه
ضمانات وهذه المذكره وكل شيء همم
ضمانه كانت باننا نحن همم ممثله
همم دول الغربيه نطلب منكم العوده الى
طاوله المحادثات واجراء كل ال معايير كنا
ندرك تماما
كانت جيده او سيئه انا ذاك كانت تحاول
تنفيذ هذه الاجراءات والرئيس حينها وافق
على كل
متطلبات للمعارضه بما في ذلك لانتخابات
المستعجله
ولكن راينا
الانقلاب وعندما سالناهم لماذا جرى ذلك
ليس لديهم اي اجابه عن ذلك
فان
الجميع سواء صحفيين او السياسيين او
ممثلين احزاب
الذين كانوا يرفعون اصواتهم لصالح تحسين
العلاقات مع روسيا كانوا يقتلون في
الشوارع
واصبح واضحا لانه لم تعد ثم فرصه
يا ستي
الدوله
الاوكرانيه فهم لن يسمحوا لنا حتى بذلك
وهذه عمليات عمليه
الممارسه الارهابيه التي كانت تتبع دون
خجل وااا عمليه غسل
الادمغهم
كنا نحاربها نراها اليوم تترعرع وتنمو
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
رموز الصليب المعقول يسيرون بحريه في
الشوارع
فكما كان الامر عليه في
التسعينيات وبدايه الالفيه الثانيه
هناك دعم للارهابيين ضد روسيا وكان كان لا
يهمهم بان هؤلاء كانوا ارهابيين معترف بهم
دوليا ولكن تم استخدامهم
واليوم يقومون باستخدام النازيين الجدد ضد
روسيا وهم لا يعنون بانهم
المهم بانهم يقاتلون ضد روسيا والان اصبح
واضحه
هذه القوه وخاصه الاوكرانيه
وكان السؤال فقط متى سيجري ذلك
وبالطبع
مرتبطه
بمئاسي والضحايا ونحن نجرك ذلك تماما
ولكن
الافضل ان يجري اليوم بدلا من غد
واعتقد ان الجميع
حاله القوات المسلحه
وافاق استخدام
الحديثه والتقنيه
التي غير موجوده في دول اخرى وكل ذلك
يعطينا مكان محدده همم لنا نحن همم
في همم القوات المسلحه والاساطير همم
وغيرها نحن نعلم ذلك وكل ذلك موجود لنا
وهو في حاله همم الحاله المطلوبه والجيده
وكل ما هو مطلوب
هو تحديث
القوات المسلحه بما في ذلك المشاه ومكافحه
البطاريات
وتعزيز الاتصالات وغيرها كل ما امم
الحاضرين هنا يدركون ان اهميه ذلك
ولكن ما اود تاكيده هنا
دول اوروبيه لانهم لم يعد لديهم اي شيء
يقدمونه سواء
في روسيا الامر لدينا كل شيء يؤكد على ذلك
لدينا كل الامكانيات
لتعزيز هذه القدرات ودون اي شك سوف نقوم
بذلك دون
حصومات وخلافه للدول الاخرى
على
بناء
وقواعدنا العلميه